is this true that you once got to meet
the great Steve Jobs that he was a fan
of yours I did I you know I used to do
Steve Jobs on Saturday Night Live right
and what was your impression my
impression was like he was so into
numbers so like he would do these like
talks where he would just like walk
around and he just be like there are 50
million downloads a day 50 million
downloads and then thank you yeah man it
was hypnotizing I loved it
it was like watching a show and then I
did the sketch where he introduced the
iPod invisi which is this tiny yeah it's
like it's invisible right like just went
between your fingertips yeah so I got to
meet him they opened this store in New
York City mm-hmm and it was like meeting
the Pope it was what they contacted you
and said mr. Jobs once his pitch yes and
so I'm just waiting there and there was
like he's gonna be in 15 minutes he'll
be here in 10 minutes and then finally
he showed up and he did this did the
invisi
to me believe it so then so then um we
took a picture but he was a little sort
of nervous about it and I was like don't
worry I will never show this anywhere
I'm not gonna post it anywhere so I have
this picture of me with him he's smiling
and I'm doing this yeah but I can't show
it because I promised I promised him I
really and by the way I almost showed it
today I was like maybe I should just do
it and then but it would be breaking a
promise yeah that we shouldn't do but
what I did was I just now backstage I
drew a picture of it picture of the
photo yeah this is cool I
did it I looked I actually looked at the
photo and I don't know where the right
place to be is right here is fine that's
and he was smiling so let's just what
should we auction that off no that's a
no I'll just keep it I'll just keep it
why would I give that away I can profit
from it I'll keep it from this terrible
job we'll be here why should some
Children's Hospital get it